[Musique]
deux films stratégies peuvent porter des
résultats inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis les chômeurs et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
bienvenue dans pôle it mag spécial
élections municipales le chômage de
masse fait partie des préoccupations des
français pour ce scrutin local dans
certaines régions en tout cas on en
débat avec nos invités sur ce plateau
stéphanie villers économiste et
spécialiste de la zone euro fasse avoue
hervé chapron ancien directeur adjoint
de pôle emploi arnaud benedetti
spécialiste en communication politique
et frédéric lazorthes chroniqueur au
magazine le point merci à tous d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
pour la première fois depuis douze ans
le chômage est en baisse en france il
s'est établi à 8,1 pour cent selon
l'insee une très bonne nouvelle s'est
félicité le président en déplacement sur
le mont blanc emmanuel macron qui a
refusé de lier une possible candidature
à la présidentielle avec ces résultats
comme l'avait fait son prédécesseur
j'allais vous dire il y en a qui ont
essayé j'avais des problèmes non moi
j'aime le sport géant sport quand on
marque un but
généralement le célèbre en dise est
formidable et c'est tout le monde est
content mais on dit pas je ne serais
content que si je gagne 2 ou 3 0 vous
voyez donc je pense est une très bon
plus sérieusement c'est une très bonne
nouvelle c'est une très bonne nouvelle
et moi je le rappelle pas ce que je lis
beaucoup de rapports d expertise
il ya cinq 5 ans avec le taux de
croissance qu'on a eu en 2019 je ne suis
pas sûr qu'on aurait recréer des emplois
donc voilà donc pour la bonne nouvelle
on va essayer de décrypter maintenant à
quoi peut-on attribuer cette baisse en
tout cas du chômage du jamais vu depuis
12 ans arnaud benedetti c'est une bonne
nouvelle mais les français n'en ont
quand même du mal à y croire
en tout cas à l'action du président sur
sur ces chiffres là plusieurs choses
d'abord parce que les français et
l'opinion publique est en général
extrêmement méfiante vis-à-vis de toute
parole publique de toute parole
institutionnelle il y un climat de
défiance qui s'est installée vous savez
c'est la fameuse phrase de mark twain
il ya trois sortes de mensonges les
mensonges les sacrés mensonges et les
statistiques en l'occurrence ils ont une
certaine forme de de doutes quant aux
quant au produit quant à la production
statistique
deuxième aspect qui est l aspect qui en
fait concerne des enjeux politiques
c'est que bien évidemment l'enjeu du
chômage reste un enjeu politique
saillants mais peut-être un peu moins
que par le passé il ya d'autres jeux qui
aujourd'hui apparaissent dans le champ
politique et qui mobilise beaucoup plus
les français et l'opinion publique je
pense l'enjeu légalité des inégalités
l'enjeu des fractures territoriales leur
jeu communautaire
tous ces enjeux viennent un peu d'une
certaine façon masquée l'enjeu très fort
qui a été d'enjeux politiques du chômage
finalement depuis 25 ans dans la vie
politique française cet enjeu a été un
enjeu dominant d'ailleurs auxquelles ont
relié bien d'autres enjeux et parmi les
enjeux que je viens de citer
en l'occurrence là il y à une sorte
finalement donnons pas de disparition
mais d'amoindrissement de cet enjeu
dans les capacités des français à se
mobiliser notamment électoralement sur
ce sujet parce que emmanuel macron aussi
on en a fait un enjeu pour pour sa
réélection comme l'avait fait françois
hollande auprès d'eric lazorthes il a
bien fait manuel macron de ne pas mettre
ça on a en avant en tout cas pour faire
un bilan de son quinquennat
probablement mais ce qui est plus
compliqué je pense quand même qu'il n'a
pas fait un objectif chiffré il y en a
quand même fait un objectif général dire
que si on regarde le ce sur quoi s'est
fait hier emmanuel macron c'est l'idée
d'une société des mobilités et derrière
cette idée de la mobilité individuelle
son image son idée de l'amélioration de
la condition de vie et générale la
société c'est de dire les gens seront
plus mobile il est de mettre l'accent
sur sa sauf que c'est là où pour
rejoindre ce que ce que dit arnaud
penalty c'est là où il ya un petit
problème c'est qu est ce que recherchent
vraiment les gens dans le travail est ce
qu'ils recherchent la mobilité où la
stabilité est est ce que cette mobilité
ils la subissent où ils en sont les
acteurs
alors il ya des tas de il ya des tas de
paramètres à prendre en compte c'est
pour ça qu'il faut décortiquer les
secteurs de du monde du travail sur
lesquelles s'appliquent les réformes en
cours mais on est passé en parler plus
en détail mais donc là il ya une vraie
problématique je pense que c'est plus
sûr derrière est ce qu'il ya une
angoisse au travail est ce qu'il ya une
anxiété
est ce qu'une satisfaction au travail
il ya des éléments que le juste le
chiffre ne permet pas de prendre en
compte donc il a eu raison de ne pas
faire un objectif chiffré mais peut-être
qu'effectivement la question n'est pas
aussi saillantes qu'elle a été pendant
longtemps
oui c'est la conception du travail
d'emmanuel macron correspond t elle à
sel
pour que s'en font les français
résistent sur un chiffre hervé chapron
deux millions quatre cent vingt-quatre
mille chômeurs d'après l'insee trois
millions cinq cent cinquante quatre
milles selon pôle emploi alors expliquez
nous ce décalage c'est vrai que ça a été
ça a été aussi un argument politique
pour dire vous voyez les chiffres c'est
encore des chiffres biaisés on n'oublie
pas tout comment est ce qu'on peut en
tout cas analysé cette différence alors
la première chose qu'on vient de dire
que c'est quand même pas nouveau que
vous avez le bureau international du
travail
il ya des normes et des normes j'allais
dire pour l'ensemble des pays et ces
normes la sont prises en compte par
l'insee et puis vous avez eu pôle emploi
qui lui fait de la statistique
arithmétique si je veux dire je fais pas
si ça a un sens pour les spécialistes
mais qu'est ce qu'on a dans le fichier
bon en fait l'insee procède plus par
sorte entre guillemets denquête et
détecte ceux qui sont qui n'ont pas de
travail
ceux qui ont du travail mais qui
aimeraient changer de travail
et puis ceux qui disent on se contente
de leur sort bon c'est une tendance
l'insee alors que pôle emploi
c'est une photographie à un instant t du
final ce que j'ai aujourd'hui dans mon
fichier pôle emploi c'est pas de l'insee
vous dit voilà les chiffres et c'est une
tendance sur trois quatre mois
voilà donc c'est une différence mais
qu'on remarque par le passé parce
qu'encore une fois c'est pas nouveau
c'est que que ce soit pôle emploi que ce
soit l'insee j'allais dire à pinède ce
prêt on retombe sur les même chiffres en
question définition est prise en compte
absolument non moi je crois que ce qu'il
faut dire sur cette baisse du chômage
qui est quand même importante c'est que
cette baisse du chômage touche toutes
les catégories les jeunes sont
particulièrement donc
les 25 49 ans un suivant les critères et
les 50 ans chaque catégorie à son compte
de baisse
et ça c'est très important elles ne font
pas ce qu'il faut quand même se souvenir
que sur le coup le chômage des jeunes
qui est quand même quelque chose
d'important et qui reste important et on
est monté jusqu'à 25%
on est à tout juste moins de 20%
c'est énorme on ne parle jamais de
l'outre-mer outre-mer chômage des jeunes
ce 48%
bon alors vous parliez de l'unité de la
population et où quand vous avez quand
même à chômage métropole de 25% un quart
des jeunes ou outremer le double ça pose
quand même des sérieux problèmes de de
tissus de perception de l'avenir et
parce qu'on n'en parle pas quand on
annonce les célébrités qui si vous
voulez pas le même
le chômage qui reste un vrai vrai gros
point noir c'est le chômage de longue
durée longue durée c'est dire au bout
d'un an
alors là on voit que les gens sont
enlisés et ne sortent pas de leur
situation
c'est en fait pour qu'on connaisse ce
qu'ils subissent le chômage de longue
durée ce sont les jeunes sans formation
donc élite la nôtre chômage en fait il
est ultra cheap et en avance en
particulier il ya des zones où on va le
voir sur la carte on a fait une carte ou
où les points sont assez critiques pour
ces jeunes qui n'ont pas qu'ils ne
trouvent pas de formation pour retourner
sur le marché donc pour voilà qui n'en
n'ont pas passé c'est un immense
problème lorsqu'on n'a pas d'expérience
et pas de formation pour entrer sur le
marché du travail
alors là il ya quand même eu aussi des
mesures qui ont été prises qui ont été
annoncées par emmanuel macron ces 15
milliards sur la table durant tout son
quinquennat pour essayer de de pallier à
ce problème et je pense que les premiers
chiffres aujourd'hui sont bons mais ne
n'arrive pas en fait à toucher cette
cette partie de la population ces jeunes
qui souffrent et qui sont à l'extérieur
de l'emploi les mesures qui ont été
prises sous forme peu pour améliorer la
formation des jeunes
elle aura une
sur le plus long terme on peut
s'attendre en plus à des résultats sur
le plus long terme à une amélioration du
taux de chômage en baisse sur les années
à venir
stéphanie muller juste je voudrais vous
faire réagir puisque l'europe à ce que
la zone euro qui est spécialiste de la
zone euro bénéficient aussi de cette
embellie depuis 2008 le taux de chômage
est au plus bas
également donc est-ce que c'est pas un
effet ricochet finalement pour la france
bah alors on a vu ce que les mesures
prises voilà ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que la france comme la zone euro a pu
bénéficier de facteurs ultra positif 1 2
puis 2 puis 2015 on va dire les taux
d'intérêt sont restés bas donc ça ça
aide les entreprises à investir
davantage on a eu aussi un euro
attractif un qui nous permettait d'être
plus compétitif à l'export
et puis un pétrole pas cher alors ça ça
soutient si vous voulez les entreprises
à embaucher davantage parce que si le
chômage baisse et surtout parce qu'il ya
eu énormément de création d'emplois ces
huit cent mille créations d'emplois
depuis cinq ans et on va voir aussi
l'infographie l'allemagne qui reste un
des pays où le taux de chômage est loin
de fort il est de 3% la france qui reste
quand même parmi les derniers 25e à 8,5
à l'époque des chiffres qui était qui
date de juillet 2010 9,8
maintenant pourquoi ce retard dans dans
cette remise en tout cas à l'emploi
depuis 2008 des de la france selon vous
ferez d'avec la zone sepa depuis 2008 en
qualité via crissement l'écart l'écart
l'écart est antérieure et il a su glisse
t il alors pour dire pour dire difficile
de caractériser ça il ya eu longtemps
quand même
le sentiment qu'une politique du chômage
c'est aussi une politique sociale en
france
en france et c'est une politique en fait
on a on a tardé à prendre en compte la
question justement des transitions
professionnelles
donc c'est une caractéristique française
qui à la fois un taux de navigation
élevé et puis une absence réellement
d'accompagnement des salariés sur les
sur les transitions professionnelles
donc on se trouvent dans des situations
où on est petit à petit exclu pour ça
que le chômage de longue durée est une
problématique pour les pouvoirs publics
et e.on en rond on a du mal à changer de
métier on a du mal à préparer les
salariés et changements de métier
le modèle du métier et même de la
dualité liées au statut
la france est un pays de statut le cdi a
été conçu par les syndicats
historiquement comme l'équivalent dans
le monde privés du statut de la fonction
publique d'abord il faut aussi voir où
et où sont installés des syndicats donc
il ya tout un ensemble de facteurs
culturels et après les pouvoirs publics
on utilisait le chômage comme je dirais
un palliatif en disant qu'au début non
et puis a même eu un traitement social
chômage et plans mettez des salades des
seniors on se disait bien prenez chômage
vous vous la retrait donnée à plus tard
et tout ça ce sont des facteurs même les
entreprises vont probablement beaucoup
moins travailler sur la question de
comment on maintient les gens dans le
travail comment on change d'avis du
travail et le chômage était une solution
vous êtes d'accord mais je vais je vais
être beaucoup plus brutale beaucoup plus
brutale
c'est denis olivennes qui parlait de
préférence pour le chômage de préférence
pour le chômage c'est quand même qu'un
deuxième chose je crois aussi que depuis
l'arrivée de les manuels macron on ne
voit que toutes les mesures toutes les
mesures et pour la première fois droit
du travail formation professionnelle
assurance chômage c'est ce que j'appelle
le grand chelem ont été attaqués de
front et non pas morceaux par morceaux
au gré des
des difficultés et je crois que ce qui
n'est pas dit mais me semble-t-il du moi
j'en ai l'intimé conviction comme disent
les juristes que emmanuel macron veut
mettre fin au traitement social du
chômage première mesure qui prend sur
l'emploi fin des contrats aidés ce que
ce que son prédécesseur avait pris comme
curseur preuve en est dernières années
du quinquennat il n'avait pas encore
déclarée qui ne se représentait pas que
fait emmanuel macron il prend le budget
de la formation professionnelle et il le
met sur les contrats aidés
on était arrivé à 500 mille contrats
aidés pour 3 milliards 5 c'est-à-dire y
retire de la formation et il fait un
traitement administratif de l'emploi
parce que le traitement social du
chômage c'est croire que le chômage est
une chose entre guillemets
administrative et non pas la résultante
d'une économie et donc me semble-t-il
que c'est d'autant plus encourageant ces
chiffres là c'est que en tant que tel
d'abord mais qu'ensuite ça traduit une
volonté d'arrêter
j'allais dire de mettre de la morphine
est plutôt d'attaqué en chirurgie alors
voilà pour le constat sauf que certains
sont
conteste ce chiffre est en tout cas
cette embellie du chômage qui n'est pas
forcément dû aux mesures prises par
emmanuel macron ils disent c'est grâce à
françois hollande
on voit dans ce tweet notamment du
sénateur ps du val-d'oise la baisse a
été en la baisse a été engagé dès 2015
soit sous françois hollande deux ans
avant emmanuel macron réaction arnaud
benedetti c'est vrai c'est pas tout à
fait faux non plus emmanuel macron peut
excéder le fait qu'il a été ministre de
l'économie de françois hollande mais
sauf que comme il se pose en rupture
vis-à-vis de françois hollande c'est un
peu difficile à tenir au niveau du
discours mais il ya quand même trois
trois éléments de modération par rapport
à ces bonnes nouvelles
d'abord il ya des disparités
géographiques qui sont extrêmement
importantes où le taux de chômage est
bien évidemment plus importants dans un
certain nombre de régions que dans
d'autres régions comme ça c'est vrai
pour la deuxième fois il ya des il ya
quand même une évolution en france qui
tendanciellement en termes de baisse du
chômage et je parle sous votre contrôle
de dire est moins forte que dans
d'autres pays voisins
ça aussi c'est une caractéristique il ya
un troisième élément c'est ce qu'on
appelle le halo autour du chômage et le
halo autour du chômage vient quand même
d'une certaine façon un peu assombrir
les chiffres et ces bonnes nouvelles que
constitue cette baisse du chômage donc
là l'eau autour du chômage c'est en fait
pour bien comprendre c'est tout un
ensemble finalement l'individu qui ne
peuvent pas pris un prix qui ne sont pas
pris en compte en raison d'un certain
nombre de caractérisation qui permettent
de dire qui est chômeur qui ne l'est pas
donc et ça sur halo autour du chômage y
reste extrêmement important puisqu'il
est je crois de l'ordre de 1 million si
soudain millions 7 qui quand même
considérable
donc s'ils voulaient ce qui explique
aussi vraisemblablement qu'une partie de
l'opinion publique reste encore quand
même extrêmement prudente quant à ces
annonces qui sont faites par le
gouvernement et que le gouvernement a
pour l'instant quand même du mal à
capitaliser sur ces résultats là oui
absolument et d'autant que ils y ont la
vue à l'écran 11 1,6 million
deux personnes qui ne sont pas inscrits
alors quelles sont les raisons
nombreuses j'imagine après les personnes
ne sont elles pas de décourager aussi de
s'inscrire avec la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui s'annonce donc
ce nom en fait de décourager augmente
c'est à dire que conditions sont de plus
en plus drastiques aussi un non en fait
ça peut être plutôt positif parce que je
vous rappelle que auparavant on disait
il nous fallait 1 25% de croissance pour
voir le taux de chômage baisser et cette
année au maximum on a eu un recul de 11%
de croissance et le chômage n'a jamais
autant baissé donc on peut se dire que
la croissance est plus riche en emplois
et donc les je pense que les français
intuitivement comprennent sans et se
dire qu'il est se disent que c'est
possible de retrouver un emploi donc ils
sont en déclarations il se déclare comme
vouloir te retrouver un emploi alors
qu'auparavant il était déclassé il se
mettait à parent du côté 1 est donc
c'est plutôt à la rigueur on moi je
pense que c'est plutôt entre guillemets
bon signe ils n'ont toujours pas
d'emplois ça c'est une réalité mais on
voit quand même qu'en face les
entreprises ont énormément de mal à
recruter sur certains emplois c'est
quand même on à 8,1 pour cent le chômage
avec des entreprises qui réclament et
qui cherche à cor et à cri des de la
main d'oeuvre et qui trouve pas alors là
c'est quand même aussi bon signe ça veut
dire qu'à un moment on va pouvoir
ajuster l'offre et la demande de la part
des formations
les entreprises aussi ont certainement
une démarche à faire il ya pas qu
uniquement
tous ne viendra pas de la politique
économique 1 et si le chômage se réduit
c'est bel et bien parce que ce sont les
entreprises qui embauchent parce que
depuis 2016 les entreprises investissent
davantage et ça c'est une nouveauté
cette question de la formation hervé
chapron est important puisqu'on il ya
des entreprises qui veulent qu'ils
veulent qu'ils veulent embaucher sauf
qu'elles n'ont pas les personnes
qualifiées pour salah la formation à
pôle emploi comme souvent est critique
et d'ailleurs
on offre des formations qui servent à
rien on en fait des formations qui est
finalement après on retrouve pas
d'emploi dans le secteur pour lequel on
a été formé alors eu mieux à porter en
tout cas c'est quand même le débat la
formation professionnelle en france
ça a été très longtemps 35 milliards ça
l'est un peu plus si lé 15 milliards
pour les nits en valais jeunes qui
bondit de suite mais c'est la formation
en france c'est le coût de
fonctionnement du ministère des armées
c'est pas n'importe quoi
il ya beaucoup d'argent dans la
formation et quand on voit les résultats
qu'on assure la formation depuis 23 ans
on peut quand même se poser des
questions et je reviens ce que vous
disiez à juste titre c'est comprenait la
formation comme un moyen tout à fait
pratique pour sortir les gens du chômage
bon c'est ça c'est indéniable
aujourd'hui il ya eu une rupture me
semble-t-il la loi sur la formation
professionnelle avenir professionnel est
bon
c'est une rupture pourquoi parce que ça
mais j'allais dire en scène sam est au
coeur du dispositif le salarié celui qui
doit se former
ça c'est le premier point deuxième point
sur pôle emploi pour l'emploi c'est
l'illustration pour l'emploi d'une
conception administrative de lutte
contre le chômage bien je ne veux qu'une
seule preuve lorsque pas l'emploi été
créés que le secrétaire d'état à
l'économie chargé de l'emploi laurent
wauquiez pour ne pas le nommer avait
réuni les cadres de l'anpe et du
de l'assurance chômage il avait du
concret pour l'emploi donc ça sera le
plein emploi dans trois ans comme si un
établissement public administratif
pouvait amener au pas lent pas au plein
emploi
bon c'est quand même assez vertigineux 1
et quand vous savez que c'est un des
plus diplômés de toute la classe
politique c'est c'est que ça devient
inquiétant
bon cela dit la critique est faite à
pôle emploi c'est que lui la formation
de sur la formation c'est un chômeur sur
dix qui seraient formés
or le slogan de la devise de pôle emploi
c'est faire plus pour ceux qui en ont le
plus besoin et vous dit non je vais pas
besoin de d2 d'aller plus loin pour
démontrer le l'ambiguïté ou du moins la
contribution de nos jours c'est quoi
cette inadéquation entre les emplois et
les formations qui seraient qui
normalement devrait pouvoir année les
français à aller vers le sait pas parce
qu'il ya déjà une vous avez déjà dans en
introduisant le sujet poser un vrai
problème
est-ce que c'est à l'entreprise de
former ses salariés
ou est ce que la formation doit être à
l'extérieur
je veux dire le rôle y un rôle social
quand même de l'entreprise et son rôle
social
ce rôle social dans ce rôle social
figurent la formation l'adaptation là là
comment l'adaptation maintenant au
numérique et ainsi de suite
bon avec les apprentis en allemagne en
fait l'allemagne à cette culture-là de
forgeval ces jeunes
associés et et en plus de ça en
allemagne si vous voulez c'est un pays
fédéral où on est dans le circuit court
si j'ose dire et c'est son origine et ce
sont les länder qui avec en fonction de
leur plan de développement économique
oriente et forme et je vais simplement
terminé pour dire que la loi notre a été
à un événement non achevée parce qu'on a
laissé aux régions le plan de
développement économique mais on leur a
pas donné la totalité de la formation et
encore moins l'accompagnement fred avec
la sorte et après on écoutera edouard
philippe justement sur l'apprentissage
là on touche un point essentiel je pense
que si on regarde sur 20 ou 30 ans la
tendance qui est le signal qui a été
donnée aux entreprises c'est la baisse
du coût du travail et cette baisse du
coût du travail
il faut bien comprendre dans un pays
l'allemagne dans le même cas il ya quand
même de fortes
il ya un paritarisme coût du travail en
allemagne est élevé d'ailleurs le coût
du travail en attente pour les bas
salaires est devenu supérieur au coût du
travail en france sont les bas salaires
donc c'est notre optique notre optique
notre choix collectif c'est le travail
peu qualifié qui coûte pas cher mais il
faut bien comprendre que pour les
entreprises c'est pas forcément un pari
gagnant puisque elles ont externalisé
tout un nombre de deux d'accompagnement
de leurs salariés et en particulier la
formation est derrière la formation
c'est la préparation de transition c'est
l'entrée dans une société de
l'intelligence des mutations de plus en
plus rapide ce qui est contradictoire en
partie avec le discours du président le
public et bien il faut préparer les
individus à cela en fait on attend le
dernier moment puis on les pousse de la
falaise et on leur dit voilà c'est
terminé ce qui crée derrière une grande
angoisse et ceux qui créent des
réticences au changement ceux qui
accompagnent les changements les
entreprises pourrait le dire
autre autre réticences l'apprentissage
les mentalités serait en train de
changer en tout cas c'est ce que dit
edouard philippe
écoutez la capacité de ceux qui suivent
ces formations à la fois dans les
centres de formation et dans les
entreprises à accéder directement un
emploi est incomparablement supérieure à
toutes les autres types de formation
donc en déverrouillant les obstacles en
essayant de faire changer le regard de
la société
sur l'apprentissage nous sommes en train
de marquer des points et je crois
sincèrement que tout ce que nous faisons
en faveur de l'apprentissage et de
l'alternance constitue une bonne
nouvelle pour la jeunesse et donc pour
le pays stéphanie villers un changement
de mentalité changement d'image de
l'apprentissage c'était nécessaire oui
il ya eu un déclic
effectivement on ça fait quand même une
vingtaine d'années qu'on essaye de
copier le modèle allemand 10 ans mais on
devrait faire pareil parce que ça marche
outre-rhin et puis on n'y arrivait pas
laisser dire que dès les deep les
diplômés bac + 2 n'avait pas du tout
envie de se trouver en situation
d'apprentissage et là il ya eu un
revirement peut-être aussi avec
l'accompagnement des entreprises un
effet magique parce qu'on voit
effectivement qui est de plus en plus de
l'entreprise en demande et d'étudiants
qui sont prêts à accepter ces contrats
d'apprentissage d'autant que auparavant
c'est vrai ils n'ont pas grand chose à
perdre ils étaient des stagiaires sans
fin et ils ont bien vu que c'était pas
un système qui fonctionnait alors que
l'apprentissage amène vers le cdi de
manière plus concrète
c'est une des clés en tout cas pour
résorber le chômage rester avec nous on
continue ce débat sur le chômage en
france on vous dit tout sur l'embellie
annoncée il ya quinze jours va-t-elle se
poursuivre ou pas on en parle dans la
deuxième partie de polypes mag a tout de
suite
[Musique]
le pire je pense en tout cas
politiquement pour l'union européenne
c'est que ça se passe bien pour les
anglais et y aura peut-être un effet
boule de neige si l'italie sort vous
avez un éclatement de l'euro et de
l'union européenne dans les mois qui
suivent
l'euro s'est pas seulement un projet
financier que c'est un projet politique
au smic le rhône fonctionne par sinon on
n'aurait pas eu un second set elle a eu
avec la grèce je suis partiellement pas
d'accord sur l'échec de l'euro on
maintient la grèce en commun à mon avis
une bonne chose vous pouvez pas vous
réjouir d'avoir votre pays qui est sous
perfusion sous assistance respiratoire
en permanence
[Musique]
oui
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation quelle que soit la
qualité expertise indéniable de nos
soldats
ils ne peuvent gagner la guerre pour la
raison que je vais maintenant fo com
peuvent faire un peu plus de 5000
militaires français à l'efficacité
certes reconnu sur une zone aussi vaste
même renforcé par cinq mille soldats
pour lui par les pays du sahel
c'est là où les problèmes ont commencé
les déclarations récentes des politiques
des spécialistes des experts des
militaires montre bien que nous sommes
face à une incompréhension totale entre
les différents acteurs
si la france n'a pas la volonté
nécessaire pour assurer la réalisation
de ses objectifs et de les accompagner
par qu'il ne s'agit pas d'imposer il
s'agit de convaincre et d'accompagner il
est à craindre que nous terminions
enlisé dans un conflit sans fin
[Musique]
polique magail la suite avec stéphanie
villers économiste et spécialiste de la
zone euro hervé chapron ancien directeur
adjoint à pôle emploi rno benedetti
spécialiste en communication politique
et frédéric lazorthes chroniqueur au
magazine le point des formations pour
les saisonniers dans les stations de
sports d'hiver
c'est la réponse du gouvernement à leurs
revendications alors que le président
lui prenait de l'altitude sur le mont
blanc en bas dans la vallée les
travailleurs saisonniers manifestaient
contre la réforme de l'assurance chômage
dont le deuxième volet va entrer en
vigueur le 1er avril prochain
aujourd'hui vu la situation de l'emploi
dans nos vallées c'est difficile d'avoir
du travail tout le temps notamment les
thés ou en période d'intersaison et donc
les indemnisations permet de survivre
dans ces petites périodes entre les
petits boulots et à la aujourd'hui ça va
être des centaines d'euros de baisses
d'indemnités qui menace
les saisonniers leurs familles les gens
ne se rendent pas compte de notre vie
hors saison c'est à dire que mai juin
septembre octobre novembre
souvent nous les femmes on a beaucoup de
mal à trouver du travail ou alors du
travail très physique
on en parlait dans la première partie la
réforme de l'assurance chômage est ce
que ça compte
est-ce que vous pensez que ça influe est
en tout cas sur les chiffres air les
chapons sur la baisse puisqu'elle est
entrée en vigueur en novembre dernier
je pense pas encore parce que si vous
voulez la réforme est progressive à
trois temps donc de temps pour les
salariés et une fois les entreprises
l'entreprise c'est pour 2021 sur le
bonus malus contrats courts là au 1er
avril ça va être sérieux ça va être
sérieux au niveau du nombre de personnes
touchées les ententes à 1 million à
millions 2 millions 3 ça va être sérieux
au niveau vers l'azur abu 15 20%
pourquoi parce que le mode de calcul le
sjr dans le jargon le salaire journalier
de référence
son calcul va être complètement
différent
il va falloir travailler beaucoup plus
longtemps encore qu'avant et
effectivement on les saisonniers ça va
poser à certains problèmes
bon si vous voulez que je fasse un petit
peu polémique
si vous voulez que je fasse un petit peu
de polémique sait on se demande presque
a directement pas frontalement aux
saisonniers et que peu avant la
négociation le ministre de la culture a
dit les intermittents du spectacle on
n'y touche pas il nous coûte quand même
un milliard les mêmes mais c'est la
paire me tente
c'est le problème de la paire mythe ans
et quelle est la différence entre la
paire mi temps ce parce que vous êtes
dans le spectacle vivant et la paire mi
temps ce parce que
il n'y a pas de neige point à point
points deux points 2 pouvez vous me dire
quelle est la différence entre un
électricien deux plateaux et un
électricien tout court on parle de
supprimer les régimes spéciaux mais
l'assurance chômage est fait de régimes
spéciaux pour le spectacle pour les
marins pêcheurs est bon donc si vous
voulez autant je félicite le
gouvernement d'avoir attaqué
frontalement droit du travail formation
professionnelle assurance chômage et
c'est la première fois que ça se faisait
je suis obligé de dire et de dénoncer
qu'il y a quand même des incohérences
dans la façon d'aborder la protection
sociale à nos benedetti pourquoi on
tousse pas aux intermittents par exemple
dans cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage c'est un tabou c'est un tabou
parce que c'était un sujet explosif et
que c'est un sujet médiatique qui est
très fort les intermittents bénéficie
d'une forme j'allais dire presque de
prescription médiatique qui fait que en
effet s'attaquer à leur statut c'est
prendre le risque finalement de rajouter
de la colère sociale à la colère sociale
qui existe aujourd'hui déjà dans ce pays
donc je crois que ça c'était aussi une
des raisons pour lesquelles quand même
le gouvernement agit step by step face
quand même un certain nombre de fronts
qu'il a ouvert depuis près de deux ans
et demi ce qui est intéressant dans la
déclaration que vous avez tout à leur
montrer de d'emmanuel macro c'est ce qui
c'est ce qu'ils disent sur le taux de
croissance et les résultats du chômage
parce que il rappelle que finalement et
en creux que il veut en tout cas
créditer sa politique manifestement des
bons résultats qui sont aujourd'hui ce
que l'on connaît en matière de chômage
et c'est bien ce que vous appelez c'est
à dire les différents dossiers auquel
s'est attaqué c'est à dire les formes de
l'assurance chômage
réforme du code du code du travail qui
était une des toutes premières réformes
qui a été présenté il faut s'en souvenir
par son gouvernement au tout début de
son mandat et il veut montrer que
finalement que malgré un taux de
croissance qui reste encore extrêmement
malgré tout qu'on le veuille ou non
assez faible il arrive à obtenir des
résultats
mais il ya un autre aspect sur lequel il
faut revenir et un petit aspect
historique d'histoires politiques
récents je rappelle qu'à une séquence
importante de diminution du chômage
entre 1997 et 2002 lors de la
cohabitation entre lionel jospin et
jacques chirac
et pour revenir aux effets politiques
finalement deux sets de 7 de cet aspect
là on voit bien que ces aspects
politiques finalement ses effets
politiques ont été quasiment nulle pour
lionel jospin
puisqu'il faut s'en souvenir le dieu
j'espère a été éliminé du second tour du
premier tour dès le premier tour
d'élection présidentielle
tout ça pour dire que in fine et encore
une fois cette question du chômage est
absolument essentiel parce que elle est
ressentie vrai sens individuel dans la
situation individuelle de chaque
français mais collectivement aujourd'hui
encore une fois les effets politiques
sur lesquels pourraient éventuellement
capitaliser le gouvernement et
l'exécutif reste largement a démontré
des effets politiques qu'on colle on
voit également au niveau local frédéric
lazorthes ans est un enjeu pour pour ces
municipales également parce qu'il ya des
régions en france qui sont extrêmement
impactés par le chômage notamment dans
le nord de la france mais de toute façon
ce qui est clair c'est qu'on pourrait
c'est le problème de la mobilité
finalement il n'y a plus de chômage dans
les bassins miniers dans nord faut bien
il faut bien voir que le du point de vue
des gouvernants du gouvernement des
points de vue technocratique on pourrait
dire il ya une à une méprise sur la
question de la mobilité
c'est vrai que les français sont
beaucoup moins mobile encore ça dépend
de génération etc
il ya des choses qu'il faut que d'autres
mais en même temps il y a des il ya des
points 2 de nombreux paramètres à
prendre en compte il ya des points où
les capacités d'emploi d'employabilité
son sont de plus en plus réduite et si
on regarde et si on regarde les secteurs
qui ont le plus touché où le chômage le
plus élevé
c'est la côte le long de la méditerranée
s le nord la france
donc l'industrie c'est là où l'industrie
a reculé mais d'autres types d'emplois
aussi ont reculé il est là vous regardez
où le front national leur ascendant sur
l'impro grèce ce sont les mêmes
territoires en réalité ce que je veux
dire je fais un contrepoint le
contrepoint anglais on le regarde pas
assez mais boris johnson et les
conservateurs depuis quelques années
s'attaque au problème de qu'on pourrait
appeler en france la smicardisation de
la société ou des revenus
si on est dans une société dans laquelle
on veut inciter les gens à reprendre du
travail il faut pas non plus les écraser
dans un salaire bas derrière donc les
travailler les conservateurs
britanniques veulent monter le smic
c'est très intéressant plus + 43 % sur
les bas salaires en grande bretagne
depuis quelques années depuis que les
conservateurs sont au pouvoir
la soie quoi ils s'attaquent c'est
justement cette crise sociale profonde
qui dit aussi en angleterre qui a
conduit au break cite entre autres et
repenser à souveraineté redire que on
doit aussi soutenir les travailleurs
pauvres que le travail doit payer
c'est le discours que nicolas sarkozy à
quelques années quand il était candidat
quand ils étaient présents le public ça
n'a pas forcément porté ses fruits mais
ça reste aujourd'hui un objectif
d'autant que la segmentation du travail
va se renforcer
autre petit élément de comparaison aux
états unis un rapport de la fed montrent
que 40 % des jeunes qui trouvent un
emploi qui sort de l'université trouver
un emploi qui n'a pas besoin de
qualification universitaire on a là
aussi un autre problème
on veut que les gens oui la
surqualification est aussi un problème
parce que la vraie le chômage et ne pas
trouver un emploi c'est un problème
encore plus grave
mais enfermé les salariés dans des dents
des je dirais des emplois qui ne
correspondent pas à leurs qualifications
est un autre problème donc faire que le
travail soit un moyen non seulement
d'activer des droits sociaux mais qu'on
le regarde plus les gens qui cherchent à
progresser dans le travail dans des
activités plutôt de les enfermer dans
des segments
c'est un travail que la santé française
doivent faire la seule française à la
fois dure vis-à-vis du chemin vous savez
que les français considèrent que les
chômeurs sont en grande partie
responsables de ce qui leur arrive et
elle est aussi très conciliante c'est à
dire que elle veut elle demande une
forte indemnisation tout ça est en train
de changer de force parce que on n'a pas
les moyens de faire ça mais il ya tout
un an une réflexion à faire sur le
travail le travail tout en la vie la
formation qui n'est même l'heureux les
entreprises qui doivent reprendre leurs
rôles kit qui reste à faire qui ne tout
ne dépend pas des pouvoirs publics ou de
l'administration vous parlez de boris
johnson s'est fmi villers dans la zone
euro effectivement la france fait partie
de cette zone euro est ce que finalement
elle a les coudées franches pour agir
sur sur le chômage on voit boris johnson
kiki hausse qui réhausse le seuil là
pour nous elle s'attaque vraiment pas
finalement alors elle n'aurait pas de
contraintes au contraire de la
commission européenne pour relancer
telle ou telle mesure elle et elle est
totale ou elle est totalement libre
pourtant avec la langue et par là la
commission plusieurs fois justement sur
le niveau de dépenses en fait ce que lui
coûte le chômage est effectivement un
prêt non non ce débat il faut pas
oublier m au coeur quand même les
entreprises françaises c'est à dire que
s'il ya du chômage c'est que les
entreprises françaises jusqu'à présent
n'ont pas assez embaucher alors la
question c'est pourquoi elle embauche
moins que les entreprises des autres
pays européens puisque je vous rappelle
qu'en allemagne le taux de chômage est à
3 en angleterre elle est aussi à 3 on
est des économies comparables alors
pourquoi nous ça ne marche pas alors il
ya eu effectivement le coût du
des salaires ça c'est effectivement que
l'industrie peut-être
et voilà et on a vu que en fait nous on
est passé complètement à côté de la
première phase de la mondialisation qui
commence dans les années 2000 où la
chine émerge effets de la production à
bas coûts et nous on fait de la
production milieu de gamme et on est
concurrencés par ces pays qui est finie
vendent des produits 100 % moins cher
donc on peut pas on peut pas arriver à
rentrer en concurrence avec ses
différentes zones la caricature il
allemagne elle a compris tout de suite
est fait les lois à son 2003 pour
assouplir fait que flexibiliser le
marché du travail et en même temps son
industrie c'est à dire les entreprises
font le choix de monter en gamme
c'est à dire que après et lg on voit
avec l'industrie automobile allemande
les mercedes lassé de ces deux
automobiles de luxe et ils n'ont pas de
concurrence à l'international donc ils
voient ils se sont ils ont réussi à
passer cette première phase arrive
maintenant c'est une deuxième phase qui
est la révolution numérique est alors la
bonne bonne nouvelle c'est à dire que
l'allemagne elle vit toujours sur ses
acquis du passé considère que faire des
automobiles
avec des telles qu'on les connaît c'est
une bonne chose
alors que nous on fait on se met en
ordre de marche on saute une étape on
n'a pas réussi
l'industrie a les yeux à rendre notre
industrie compétitive dans les années
2000 mais on est en train de le faire
alors ça depuis comme je vous disais
d'investissement est reparti en france
depuis 2016 et l'investissement pourrait
repartir dans les seuls dans des
secteurs moribond ce qui apporterait
rien à l'emploi mais on voit que non
elle est bien orienté globalement je
parle au niveau macro puisque je n'ai
que ces tendances là et on voit que
l'investissement des entreprises en fait
part dans l'immatériel donc c'est à dire
tout ce qui touche le numérique book
pour demain on est en train de rentrer
dans cette nouvelle vague et on sera en
ordre de marche alors que d'autres pays
ne le seront pas alors là vous parlez du
numérique en ce qui concerne les
industries en tout cas on a vu
délocalisation des emplois des plans de
licenciements assez massif nommément et
fleuron français
justement est ce que là aussi la
politique d'accompagnement de retour à
l'emploi des personnes n'ont pas été
suffisantes par nous benedetti
vraisemblablement mais si vous voulez la
grande difficulté c'est que enfants sont
là une approche très idéologique de
cette question du chômage ce qui
différencie vraisemblement de
l'allemagne on a une approche
idéologique parce que tout simplement on
considère que ce sont des politiques
macroéconomiques ou c'est l'état en
l'occurrence qui vont permettre
d'une certaine manière un moment donné
d'assister au retour au travail ou voir
surtout de protéger également jaillir
l'allemagne a une toute autre démarche
et c'est ce qui différencie vrai sens
moment si vous voulez le traitement du
chômage entre l'allemagne et la france
cette culture politique française qui
fait que indéniablement on assigne à
l'état une sorte quasiment que j'allais
dire presque de pensée magique une
certaine façon qui va permettre de
résoudre la difficulté et ça ce contexte
culturel il est extrêmement important
parce qu'ils pèsent extrêmement sur les
acteurs sociaux regardez la façon dont
le dialogue social en france se
construit regarder la façon dont le
dialogue social est construit en
allemagne ce qui s'explique aussi ce qui
s'explique aussi du fait de la façon
dont l'état à été construit parce que
l'état est construit en france de
manière verticale de manière centrale ce
qui est tout à fait différent en
allemagne où on a un état qui s'est
construit d'une façon tout à fait
différente donc si vous voulez le
contexte les cadres politiques les
cadres culturels explique bien bien des
biens des difficultés et bien des enjeux
auxquels nous sommes confrontés
il serait avec les embrouilles et réagir
le complément sur ça c'est
qu'effectivement le face à face entre
les individus et l'état c'est un trait
de caractère français à tel point même
que quand vous regardez aujourd'hui
réellement oust et l'emploi
il ya deux pistes qu'on cherche c'est
trouver vous même votre emploi donc
créer votre propre emploi
depuis des années les politiques de
l'emploi vont vers les auto
entrepreneurs le statut d'indépendant
mais ça n'est pas très fructueux puisque
l'essentiel du système est basé sur des
grosses organisations centrale en
particulier et les métropoles
ce ne sont pas les grandes entreprises
qui embauchent donc tout repose sur des
pme et le soutien et la vraie question
le retard français en particulier sur le
plan industriel
c'est que on tarde on a tardé on trouve
pas les instruments qui conviennent pour
soutenir ces pme qui accuse toujours les
chocs économiques et notamment
industriels alors ce qui est compliqué
sur les délocalisations c'est qu'on se
rend compte que la délocalisation n'est
pas forcément une bonne affaire du point
de vue économique et que des savoir
faire qui partent ne permettent pas à un
développement d'une entreprise donc il
ya un rapatriement de pas mal de savoir
faire mais qui ont été perdus
d'entreprise dans le domaine industriel
mais il ya vraiment une réflexion à
faire sur le soutien de tout le tissu de
pme que les que les allemands sont
beaucoup plus fort sur ce domaine là
donc c'est structurellement pour
reprendre question ils ont peut-être
pris du retard numérique mais ils savent
soutenir l'ensemble des secteurs
économiques industriels
alors qu'en france il ya une habitude
des grands entreprises à jouer sur leurs
sous traitants et en fait derrière à
avoir un problème de désertification
industrielle est pourquoi le l'emploi et
plus aujourd'hui il ya même des chiffres
qui sont à moins de 7% dans les
métropoles
hervé chapron saas explique comment les
entreprises s'implantent davantage dans
les vies avant de répondre à votre
question
je voudrais dire que la france pour la
france et encore aujourd'hui l'état
c'est l'état providence on attend tout
de l'état et ne pas réfléchir au
périmètre de l'état me semble-t-il est
une faute fondamentale
bon ça c'est le premier point à la
france
la france a les caractéristiques sur les
problèmes de l'emploi c'est son service
public de l'emploi
savez vous combien il coûte par an et
coûte 110 milliards et toute politique
publique de l'emploi est fortement
centralisé le ministère et comme vous le
disiez la verticale et ça dégringole
jusqu'aux sous préfet bon ça sa peau je
pense qu'elle la déperdition en ligne
comme on dit donc voilà centralisée
c'est ce qu'annonce a coûté moi je suis
un fervent décentralisateur et
particulièrement des politiques de
l'emploi
j'estime ce que j'estime que ou la
région doit être en mouvement ou alors
c'est pas la peine d'avoir des régions
c'est tout simple je suis pour les
circuits courts comme monde yves en
agriculture mais c'est l'expression
qu'il faut retenir
et je considère que les structures qui
font des
plan stratégique économique doivent
avoir comme à la capacité de les mettre
en oeuvre
l'accessoire suis le principal appris ça
il ya ya très longtemps
donc voilà donc pour pour je pense que
philosophiquement psychologiquement
l'état providence qui ne fonctionnent
plus et encore très très ancré dans la
population et on attend beaucoup
beaucoup et beaucoup trop de l'état qui
est endetté
c'est ce qu'on a vécu la crise des
légendes a été de ce point de vue là un
formidable révélateur parce que la crise
des vielles jaune c'est aussi quand même
une demande d'états qui s'exprime à
travers notamment la question des
services publics et aussi la question du
consentement à l'impôt à travers la taxe
carbone donc on voit bien que ce sujet
restent encore extrêmement fort dans la
société et la contradiction à laquelle
on assiste c'est que si vous voulez vous
avez d'un côté en effet un mouvement qui
change un peu la culture des français
dans cette relation à l'économie ou de
cette relation sociale où on considère
qu'on effeuille responsabilité
individuelle et ce sentiment malgré tout
se développe notamment chez les jeunes
mais en même temps vous avez le
phénomène qui reste persistant d'une
demande de l'intervention de l'état pour
tout simplement amortira certain nombre
de champions sur la question qu'il faut
se poser aujourd'hui c'est que contenu
quand même des chocs de mondialisation
que la société française a connu qu'est
ce que serait la société française
aujourd'hui si elle n'avait pas eu ces
amortisseurs sociaux qui malgré tout ont
permis de maintenir un minimum de
cohésion sociale
et ça c'est quand même une question
aujourd'hui qui se pose alors une
embellie dans les chiffres du chômage on
va écouter
muriel pénicaud qui a été interrogée sur
est-ce que ça va continuer ce que
l'ambition de 2 7% à la fin du
quinquennat est tenable
écoutez 8,1 pour cent de taux de chômage
c'est la preuve que l'ambition de 7%
elle n'est pas gagné d'avancé n'est
toujours pas gagné d'avancé mais elle
est franchement je pense atteignable
stéphanie muller c'est réaliste
la continuer alors il ya quinze jours je
vous aurais dit oui avec le coronavirus
et ce qui me fait ça on est face à un
défi que enfin qu'on a du mal à chaque
mois la théorie c'est fun c'est pas le
même oui mais on risque d'avoir si on
voit le ce qui se passe ce qui s'est
passé en chine ya quand même eu un arrêt
total des entreprises 80% de la
production qui a été stoppée est bon et
maintenant on pensait que c'était la
chine était le seul foyer d'infection
s'aperçoit depuis la semaine passée que
finalement l'europe est touchée donc ce
qui veut dire que on va devoir prendre
les mêmes mesures si on veut endiguer
cette épidémie et ça si c'est si la
durée de l'épée nos métiers l'épidémie
est longue ça ça risque d'avoir des
conséquences dramatiques sur la
croissance et donc sur l'emploi un là il
faut il faut prendre mais bon si
beaucoup de sicile épidémie arrive à
être rapidement endiguer oui c'est
possible puisqu'on sait qu'il faut
maintenir une croissance aux alentours
de 1% il faut savoir que quand même le
chômage baisse mais parce que parce que
l'activité est là bas on peut pas créer
du chemin malgré des saisons variables
sont en récession
ça c'est le logo dit quand même que la
dynamique de création d'emplois sera
peut-être moins deux fois moins
importante en 2020 qu'en 2019 plutôt
pessimiste oui bah oui c'est selon ces
scénarios
moi c'est pas un scénario que je partage
sauf avec cette nouvelle hypothèse qui
est qu'on est bien obligé d'intégrer
dans nos modèles et avec beaucoup
d'incertitudes beaucoup de difficultés
je pense qu'aujourd'hui plus personne ne
peut vraiment faire une estimation
crédible puisque on attend les résultats
du développement de ces tv pc déposés
sur l'économie on en reparlera
évidemment on va passer au dernier
moment
frédéric lazorthes on va passer aux
résultats de notre sondage juste sur la
question de l'attitude des entreprises
il ya un indicateur c'est que le
président du medef indique aujourd'hui
le curseur était sur les gains de
productivité c'est les entreprises
françaises ont dans la dernière année
embaucher davantage qu'eux
dans les deux dernières années que dans
les années précédentes maintenant gagne
productivité en contexte de crise et si
un ralentissement la croissance c'est
très clair c'est moins embauches ça
c'est le premier élément le deuxième
encore une fois pour voir les impacts
d'une crise économique type courant d'un
virus ou autres sur l'économie sur les
revenus des français est bien le
problème c'est qu'il ya des tas de
secteurs qui sont non visibles qu'ils
sont justement les travailleurs
indépendants les gens qui sont qui sont
pas inscrits au chômage qui vont leur
propre activité et tous ses amortisseurs
qui sont des amortisseurs économique
derrière il n'ya pas d'art antisocial
une des promesses de macron je termine
juste sur sa qui était de favoriser le
travail indépendant les ruptures
extraire les choix derrière y'a pas le
on n'a pas encore le système social
d'accompagnement ni économique ni
sociale ni social qui permet ça en fait
en réalité pour ça que le financement de
bismarckien passant méridien en d'autres
termes on est de la cotisation à la peau
moins chaud et tout ça quasiment comme
une lettre à la poste même réflexe de
gains de pouvoir d'achat
sauf qu'on a comme on change
complètement le logiciel de l'âpreté de
la protection sociale
on arrête j'allais dire le côté filières
professionnelles et on passe pas par
l'impôt et comme alibi on dit ah mais le
professionnel c'est du corporatisme
ce sera le mot de la fin on va passer
aux résultats de notre sondage après
enfants
[Musique]
on a posé la question sur nos réseaux
sociaux le chômage at il baissé selon
vous grâce à emmanuel macron grâce à
françois hollande ou bien ni l'un ni
l'autre voilà pour la question et bien
vous voyez à les résultats grâce à
l'avancé 6 % de nos téléspectateurs 5 %
pour françois hollande presque le même
chiffre 2 % grâce à l'europe et 86%
aucun des trois voilà c'était pour la
blague autour du chômage 2 des français
qu'il ne croit pas non plus que les
politiques sont responsables de
l'embellie c'est ce qu'on disait un
temps que les entreprises ne sont pas
non plus impliqué les choses ne
s'amélioreront pas durablement merci
beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir accepté de
débattre sur le plateau de polypes mag
est resté avec nous à l'info à suivre
[Musique]
aussi on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort